a science experiment on groups of boys
from competing camps who have no idea
they're being manipulated into fighting
each other what was all that about
[Music]
in the summer of 1954 a school bus with
a group of 11 and 12 year old boys
arrived at Robbers Cave State Park in
Oklahoma what the kids didn't know there
was another bus
all the boys thought they were going
camping their parents at home believe
the sponsored trip had something to do
with the leadership none of them knew
that the Camp staff were actually
researchers and the boys part of a
controversial experiment one of its
goals let the boys fight each other
the robbers cave experiment was designed
to unfold in three stages in-group
formation friction and conflict
resolution
it started with in-group formation in
the first week each group did various
activities without interwriting with
another the boys had fun when swimming
and did hikes
over time social norms developed leaders
and followers emerged the boys formed
friendships and started inventing their
own subculture
eventually they came up with names one
group called themselves the Eagles and
the others chose to be the Rattlers they
stenciled their names onto shirts and
flags the in groups were formed the
tribes had an identity they were now
ready to meet each other
during the friction phase the two groups
came into contact with each other the
researchers set up competitions with
single prizes for the winners in other
words they established a limited
resource for the two to battle over
it didn't take long before the in-groups
developed negative attitudes towards the
out-group Prejudice became apparent to
make matters worse the staff suggested
to one group to dump buckets of mud
inside the cabin of the others
eventually the kids grew hateful violent
and verbally abusive they burned each
other's flags and sometimes things
escalated to the point that the Camp
staff had to step in
last was conflict resolution the boys
were meant to make peace first the staff
tried to reduce the Prejudice between
the groups by increasing contact and
communication but that just made matters
worse
then the researchers blocked the valve
to the Camp's water tank as there was no
more drinking water the boys became
progressively thirstier then the Camp
staff suggested that they all needed to
collaborate to fix the problem
reluctantly the group started to get to
work
[Music]
yeah
before long the boys were mixing and
cooperating there were no Rattlers or
Eagles anymore only a bunch of campers
collaborating when the water finally
came through there was common rejoicing
the researchers learned four key things
from the experiment
[Music]
first individual differences are not
responsible for tribal conflicts age
race culture or religion don't seem to
matter
second hostile attitudes arise when
groups compete for resources that only
one of them can get
third discussions don't solve conflicts
fourth only a common goal or enemy that
promotes cooperation reduces the
friction
two renowned psychologists Mustafa
Sharif and his wife Carolyn wood Sharif
were behind the controversial experiment
and later established a theory
realistic conflict theory explains how
hostility arises as a result of
competition for limited resources such
as money power military protection or
social status whether these resources
are actually limited or just perceived
to be so doesn't matter
[Music]
their work helps us understand the
mechanisms of discrimination against
Outsiders which escalates during
shortages for example when in groups
think that good jobs are hard to find
they often try to remove sources of
out-group competition Lobby for legal
restrictions or deny newcomers access
[Music]
what do you think do tribal conflicts
only arise as a result of competition
for scarce goods and if so are shared
goals and common enemies really the only
way to peace
or is the theory flawed and not
applicable to adults after all children
are easier to influence not only to
build a Prejudice but also to change
their ideas again later share your
thoughts in the comments below
[Music]
if you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation you
can support us visit patreon.com Sprouts
just visit us learn how it works and
what's in it for you we hope to see you
there
and if you are a parent or educator
check out our website
sproutschools.com there you can find
this and other video lessons additional
resources and classroom activities